[Music]
see what happened to to boozy
oh yeah I was gonna play this on
nightwave and I never got to it Friday
well then let's get to it today
I love how TMZ watermarks
a body cam footage which is just public
it's like Freedom of Information in the
watermarket
foreign
oh they're handcuffing him
yeah why was he detained what did he do
that they pulled him over
uh so they originally pulled him I
watched this whole thing by the way
anything Boosie related I'm always all
in okay this is honestly not a very
eventful video other than him kind of
going off right you know it's it's like
your typical Boosie situation where it's
it's a mundane routine thing but Boosie
makes it great because right she's busy
but he got pulled over initially for uh
they one of the reasons was [ __ ]
they said that they his plates were
obscured like his you know they couldn't
read the the license plates which is
[ __ ] because the body cam shows
later like you could read the license
plate okay but they mostly pulled them
over for the tent right because it's a
rapper car so it's like oh so limo 10
yeah probably 22s and [ __ ] yeah like it
was just one of those things they pulled
him over for being looking like Boosie
and having a tint and look I did when
you see his um driver too you can just
see like this is this was a straight up
like profile
but okay I understand so
I understand that they pulled them over
because of the tint right like you said
it was the tint or whatever let's say
it's the obscured tag fine also that
why are they handcuffing him like he
didn't they that's the part I don't get
they smelled weed okay come on which oh
this is in Georgia oh
I got 12th weed and this is Georgia
Georgia Highway Patrol yeah and I think
usually cops are full of [ __ ] when I do
that you smell that yeah you smell that
partner yeah like but this is Boosie
we're talking about I've watched Vlad TV
interviews with him he's never not
smoking a blunt got it so even if he
didn't have it in the car he was
definitely smoking a blunt up until
seconds as he was getting into the car
got it laughs
I don't know it seems a little even but
fine even if you smell the weed why
would you handcuff somebody
oh uh they're black oh
you're right merch I'm such and it's
George I'm such an idiot okay can I
before we go on sure sure I did find
Rachel Levine's
um
uh metals okay what are they whatever
um
by the way I'm reading this from an
article okay that's very critical of
Rachel Levine okay so this I may
accidentally misgender Miss Levine okay
because I'm reading from this article
which by the way this article is you
shouldn't be writing like the Terrible
Things
um whereas the office of the Secretary
of Health and Human Services
identification badge
uh and then the uh when when she first
arrived thank you thank you herself
thank you with the Army's presidential
troops award for Public Health Service
okay new Crown anti-epi epidemic medal
I guess it's probably a [ __ ] coveted
one Public Health Service regular troops
and active duty troops training medal
so
it goes to show you
what a [ __ ] scam covet is and was
that that they they had this terrible
pandemic where people are dying they had
time to vote on and approve a new
coveted medal specifically I don't know
if it's if it is new Crown anti-epidemic
medal could be I don't know maybe an old
I all I know is they're all medicine
related and they're all almost pretty
much civilian
like error level things I don't know I
just I didn't mean to interrupt the
Boosie thing I just [ __ ] civilians
you just award yourself ribbons okay
so
Moosie got pulled over because I just
want to make sure I got everything in a
rope Lucy got pulled over because he
they said they couldn't see us played
him because he had the tinted windows
the cop said that they smelled weed
and that's why they pulled them out at
least their reasoning for handcuffing
him that's where we are right now
Georgia Highway Patrol yeah yeah
I mean Georgia is one of those States
when if you got weed and [ __ ] on you you
[ __ ] drive the speed limit through
Georgia just just telling you
I'm just telling you and you don't like
have the certain states where even if
you got weed or whatever it's not a bit
there's a difference between having weed
and there's a difference between like
just having it out all just strewn about
your car yeah you know roaches and [ __ ]
like that's where you get into trouble
yeah it's got a vape or whatever you
tuck some [ __ ] away you make sure you're
not smoking in the car you're in and out
of these [ __ ] transactions with these
guys but when you're just that you could
tell that like when they start searching
the truck it's like they've been smoking
it at a certain point like it but but
they didn't find any in the truck no
they found like a couple of little
roaches and [ __ ] but I don't think they
busted them
yeah all right is drinking marijuana
that comment or any other drugs
you're good I got you it's always you're
honest with me I want you okay
bro
like bro I gotta go to y'all Superior
and file charges man this harassment
it's everyday
so I'm assuming this has happened before
yeah he's um boost he's from Louisiana
but he's pretty much like hung his hat
in Georgia in Atlanta yeah like the
Atlanta area all right all right
I'm glad you're here because you're
you're more than you're more the hood
I'm a Boosie historian yes thank you
exactly
we should just make a channel called the
boozy historian and play like
Masterpiece Theater music behind it and
just go through all his charges
Woody stop saying you live in the
[ __ ] country all right let's let's
stop with this I learned how to live in
the country you're like 10 miles out
from Atlanta stop it okay Brookhaven
Georgia yeah I don't want to [ __ ] oh
I'm sorry you're in Buckhead shut up
exactly I don't want to out in the
country there's a Cheesecake Factory
you're not out in the country
I liked it
I'm going there
what's he saying
every [ __ ] body for some time bro
I'm ready to [ __ ] roll me
coming up on uh still trying to
understand the handcuffs even if they
smell the weed that seems weird
honestly they've been doing that a lot
lately cops that ever since the Floyd
stuff yeah there's no more of this like
I mean sometimes you maybe you know
especially in Florida I think they're a
little more
Florida cops are a little more freedom
based where they're like you know
they're not going to take in cuffs until
they're really whatever but once they
smell weed and they're searching
nowadays A lot of them are afraid of
having a Chase or hurt somebody and
they'd rather have them I mean I get
that look honestly logically that does
make sense to me I I get that it's just
[ __ ] sometimes when they didn't do
anything right I just walked we I just
broke down one a couple weeks ago on
nightwave in Orlando this black kid that
got pulled over oh you were telling me
about this one and he was just like he
[ __ ] didn't do anything and he just
sat there he never said a word and it
got they were really assholesome the
whole time until towards the end when
they really had nothing on them and they
knew they were gonna have to cut him
loose and they knew all the [ __ ] they'd
been talking for like 40 minutes this
car was like and then they were like hey
man if I let you go you in the pool well
sudden they were like hey man sorry
about that
but yeah they have the coffee dude
he's also not talking his way out of
those cups
you're not making me want to take
handcuffs off of you right now what I'm
saying is that I also like to be
realistic right and look I get the
reason why I'm not trying to be too I'm
not even being judgy about it but we
know if that was two white girls in a
[ __ ] Scion and they load the window
and it smelled like weed they're not
going to be getting handcuffs they might
still search their car and [ __ ] but you
know they're not getting handcuffs you
know it and I know it yeah Royce but
these are black guys oh you're right I
forgot
again merch thank you Merc is very good
at reminding me when it's because
they're black guys are you kidding me I
wish I was able to handcuff black men
while just doing Simple transactions
with them at the store
you know but how would they scan your
items the guy that just works at Tires
Plus I'm like can this guy be handcuffed
while I'm doing business with that
you're such an he scares me
[Laughter]
the poor black guy in the Tires Plus I
know shirt just coughed on man this is
some [ __ ] man it never ends it never
ends oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh
wait he's tired
by the way you know what I love too is
like you're really seeing privilege at
work right now right
because here you have the rich famous
black guy who has privilege so he's just
chimping out and threatening everybody
right next to him you have his associate
who's a young black man probably ain't
got [ __ ] and that guy is keeping his
mouth shut very good point he has he
does not have privilege he knows that if
he starts mouthing off like this he'll
just go to prison you're seeing both
sides of that Chris Rock joke right now
right now no you know what I mean you're
seeing both sides of it right now and
both of them
the duality of man is what you're saying
the other one's like I just want to get
out of here he just wants to get home so
he could smoke weed in his house he is
man I just want to go home and smoke
weed and play 2K leave me alone oh God
it's so funny that's a really good
observation man you're looking at just
the two two completely different ways to
handle this situation just yeah
I'm gonna make you charge me
I'll show you how I can I think he's
getting annoyed by Boosie I think his
friends even the driver's like bro shut
up he's not saying because he pays him
probably well yeah but he's just like
can he just can he just stop it again
like I've been pulled over seven times
this week
[Laughter]
pressing one time
I have a master's degree you know what
you're
you're a master's degree he's probably
got a like a bachelor's in in like Sound
Engineering and he's going back yeah I'm
going back to [ __ ] grad school he's
Jessica said he's like God damn torn
shut the [ __ ] up he's talking about his
real name goddamn Torrance shut the [ __ ]
up bro all I do is smoke weed skateboard
and make beats I mean I mean seriously
yeah man except when this [ __ ]
because his license is never good yeah
and I go cool I'll get you at the
airport sure
and it's always a problem and we always
have to take his car which always has
drugs in it so then we're fine I told
them I'll take mine he's like nah man I
don't roll with that [ __ ] so what am I
supposed to do
exactly bro I got a brand new Dodge
Charger yeah
we'll blend in in Georgia yes seriously
sometimes they think it's a cop car okay
like honestly you want to roll around in
a bulletproof SUV with [ __ ] cyber
truck Windows somebody in the chat I
pulled over somebody in the chat goes or
maybe the guy the driver downed all the
drugs and that's why he's spaced out
exactly he made him eat it everything
and it's hitting him right now oh [ __ ]
so when I get locked up
laughing oh my God I think you nailed
the situation he's like laughing like
[ __ ]
okay you know you're gonna like a
gangster I [ __ ] get it I have
reservations tonight with my fiance so
look listen Torrance can you please calm
down I guarantee you this is a guy that
makes Beats or something I think you're
right I think he's that kind of black
guy the one that doesn't really go out
in the streets and [ __ ] anime black guy
I think he's an anime black guy all I do
is watch anime smoke weed and make beats
that's it that's it yeah
this is a guy who skateboards and
listens to Wu-Tang like you know like
he's you know what I mean I I know
exactly what this kind of thing you know
it's multiple backpacks yes exactly
exactly
I'm ready now
it's on the first white boy
okay see what if the white boy didn't do
anything yeah
what if like the first White point you
see is like chocolate now
you know what I mean like [ __ ] what
are the first white boy you see is Frank
Mir are you the one that's the one that
just came the last yeah yeah I think
you're gonna punch cage Velasquez in his
face
no not even even better the first rifle
he sees was he's supposed to be on
Brendan chops podcast so he tries to
punch Brendan and say what you want
about him but Penny would knock this guy
the [ __ ] out there
you're [ __ ] with a treasure
[ __ ]
I will say this though
he he I have seen and heard stories of
Lucy he will throw down yeah
yeah but you know who's actually worse
the baby
yeah baby straight up kills people
although the babies freak out that we
had that we played a couple months ago
was [ __ ] hilarious and the best thing
about it is he's killed so many people
and he's never done it day a time for it
because it's always defensive yep he's
literally killed like three people that
have come for him he shot that dude at a
Walmart yes
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] this this gets uh interesting
though
[ __ ] I swear to God bro I want God
every [ __ ] day
every [ __ ] thing I'm getting before
the way of my people
I'm getting targeted bro
my license plate is right I'm targeting
it might never birth control pills or
something for one of my [ __ ]
that's all
birth control pills or something my
pictures
you know [ __ ] can't get pregnant from
yeah I got a lot of hoes sucking in my
house right now huh yeah
I got like 35 holes sucking at my house
right now if anybody won't think
something let me know
yes I would like to get my dick sucked
no but I'm why is this why is this the
situation there's no hoes around
sir there's not a hole in the vicinity
well because they're in that at the
house are condensed no I get it but I'm
can't be sucking dicks out in the
[ __ ] highway oh my God the other I
just noticed the other guy's on his
phone he's like yeah honey I'm gonna be
late he's texting I'm gonna be late
again
boozy boozy's [ __ ] being an [ __ ]
again you look at him he really he's
using his phone maybe I told you to stop
[ __ ] with him I told you to just tell
him to get a [ __ ] Uber baby
I could fight I would throw them [ __ ]
within the office
[ __ ] dude [ __ ] chill out man
I mean I guess this is unfair I got it
but you're being very aggressive can we
give this guy props he's definitely been
in handcuffs enough times that he's
learned how to get his phone out and use
yep she's pretty
pretty good right that's not something
that's learned that man has been in
handcuffs many times and has probably
been polite every time I've been like
hey can I just text my girl real quick
I'll I'll behave just let me talk to my
girl
's not stolen registration is right
the tag is right I was pulled over
because it's boosted cars
you [ __ ] [ __ ] are targeting
my vehicle
you're targeting my vehicle
if I was a white college player you
wouldn't [ __ ] with my vehicle if I
played soccer or baseball you wouldn't
[ __ ] with my vehicle
they'd [ __ ] with your vehicle
yeah they would [ __ ] with athletes all
the time the athletes get arrested all
the time all the time
especially autograph yeah
I will give you a citation for number
one so they give him a citation for weed
all right
for the smell of marijuana
yeah
oh my God yeah but this is stupid I mean
come on really why why
are we still doing this for weed man
it's so stupid right
it is all right
ice cream
all right I'll let y'all be on busted
are we good yeah okay we'll take the
handcuffs off
this guy other guy hasn't said a word
[Music]
bro I'm just tired
you let me go just let me go boy I'm
going file charges right now
okay
anyway
he got very mad
like very very mad okay yes